everyone messes up pronouns at some
point and especially when people are
learning it's just all about respect
it is not a major news story when
hollywood celebrities say really stupid
things a lot of kids are being swept
away in the same stupid social craze
called transgenderism that demi lovato
was swept away with and demi lovato will
face zero consequences from it for the
kids who are looking to her and and more
importantly looking to people who have
even more cultural and political
influence than her and looking to the
public health officials that are that
are pushing this on kids and looking to
the big pharma companies that are
peddling this to little kids those kids
are not going to get out so easy those
kids are going to have lots of long-term
health problems they're all going to
have intense psychological scarring and
their lives are in many ways going to be
deeply damaged if not ruined because of
this ideology so it's funny it's cool
that demi could try that on for a little
bit hahaha okay but now i'm she again
tahihi but
what about the people
who will have to pay the price hollywood
never has to pay the price for anything